ahora tenemos mucha experiencia
realizando en límites de funciones por
ejemplo podemos pensar en el límite de
fx cuando x tiende a un cierto valor a y
que este límite sea igual a un cierto
valor l hasta ahora todo lo que hemos
hecho es trabajar con un valor finito
para sin embargo cuando vemos la gráfica
de la función f que tenemos aquí puedes
ver que algo interesante ocurre cuando x
es cada vez más grande parece que
nuestra función f se acerca más y más a
2 observan tenemos una sin tota
horizontal en igual a 2 de manera
similar cuando x tiene valores más y más
negativos también podemos observar que
tenemos la misma sin tota horizontal en
igualados existirá algún tipo de
notación que establezca lo que le pasa a
la gráfica cuando x toma valores muy
grandes o muy pequeños la respuesta son
los límites en el infinito si queremos
pensar a qué valores se aproxima la
función cuando
y es cada vez más grande podemos pensar
en el límite de fx cuando x tiende a más
infinito
esta es la anotación en este momento no
voy a dar la definición formal espero
que podamos hacerlo en futuros vídeos en
esta ocasión parece que nuestra función
se aproxima a un valor finito cuando x
es cada vez más y más grande la función
se aproxima a nuestras into está
horizontal por lo tanto en esta función
podemos decir que este límite se
aproxima al valor de 2 y para esta
función en particular el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a menos infinito también
parece que se aproxima a 2
no forzosamente debemos obtener el mismo
valor podríamos tener el siguiente caso
para eso dibujaré otras into está
horizontal por acá intentaremos imaginar
una nueva función que se vea así se
mueve por aquí después sube hasta acá y
después baja de nuevo ya sea algo como
esto
en esta nueva función el límite cuando
extiende a más infinito sigue siendo 2
pero el límite cuando x tiende a menos
infinito es menos 2 también podríamos
tener una situación donde ya sea que el
límite cuando x tiende a más infinito oa
menos infinito no se aproxima en ningún
valor finito
es decir no se aproxime a ninguna a sin
tota horizontal sin embargo lo más
importante de este vídeo es que esta
anotación te sea familiar es decir los
límites en el infinito o podemos decir
el límite en más infinito y en menos
infinito ambos tienen una definición
formal distinta a los límites que
aprendimos anteriormente donde nos
aproximábamos a un valor finito pero al
menos de una manera intuitiva espero que
esta idea de que son límites tenga
sentido para ti nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo